oui georges fauré même le champion déchu
est déçu accuse et se contredit mon
combat dit-il contre ali s'est déroulé
d'une façon irrégulière orbite m'a conté
trop rapidement
le règlement lui répond larbi doit
compter à partir du moment
une autre partie du corps que les pieds
touchent le sol
nous avons nous mêmes chronos mais c'est
la séquence du kao corp émane était
debout sans garde arconce seconde il le
dit lui-même d'ailleurs j'ai eu
l'impression d'être debout
à dix c'était un ko technique et non pas
un chaos alors monsieur for human soyons
sérieux faut rehman porte une seconde
accusation
regardez bien la position de craie qui
sa fille contre les cordes freeman dit
mon adversaire se trouvait très souvent
assis dans les cordes comme sur une
chaise les corps ont été détendu
le règlement dit qu'il est interdit de
se servir de la flexibilité des cordes
pour frapper de plus des cordes d'un
ring assure uniquement la sécurité des
boxeurs elles sont là pour éviter qu'il
ne tombe enfin l'entourage de faure
émane pouvait très bien vérifier si les
corps n'étaient bien entendu c'était son
droit le plus malin troisième point de
l'accusation le tapis du ring qui selon
forêt man était trop mou et combiné au
catch plus qu'à la boxe que dit le
règlement la matière un tapis de rim
réglementaire et en push ou en
caoutchouc
son épaisseur varie d'un centimètre 5 à
1 centime et nos forêts mal et son
entourage avait aussi toute latitude
effectuer ces vérifications